bonjour dans une poubelle à sortir notre
premier tour je voulais faire un métier
qu'un uniforme symbolique je pense
l'éducation que j'ai reçue avec voilà
être carré uniforme
michael a de la bouteille 18 ans qu'il
s'est engagé sur la coursive autrement
pas toujours sortir la peine quand on
ouvre une parcelle pour éviter de se
retrouver coincé à l'intérieur un moyen
de sécurité en plus il ya une certaine
barrière à franchir donc et après on est
là pour moi fait l'autorité aussi pour
leur apprendre la queue on en prison et
qu'il ya des règles à respecter
on est pas leurs amis le goût du
règlement un certain respect pour
l'ordre la promenade
ces cinq par cinq pas plus en presque
vingt ans la sécurité est devenue
priorité absolue celle des détenus
celle des gardiens aussi il m'a marqué
c'est au début de ma carrière dans les
quartiers mineurs leur jeu ils avaient
un jeu c'était de mettre les matins
contre les portes est de les allumer le
met le feu dessus pour que nous comptons
nous les portons s'éprennent dessus sauf
qu'un jour ils ont tellement bien bloqué
le matelas que ça a fait gonfler la
porte et on n'a pas pu ouvrir la porte
et au bout de deux jours dix minutes un
quart d'heure qu'on a réussi à faire
tomber la porte
les deux mineurs étaient décédés par le
feu ça c'est une scène qui m'est resté
quand même pas mal dans la tête et pour
avoir le jeu contre le moral fall mental
et puis après il faut essayer de faire
abstraction et continuer son métier
les drames il y en a toujours mais
depuis quelques années la prison suit de
très près ces prisonniers qui ils sont
comment ils en sont arrivés là
l'histoire se découvre dans la fiche
pénale il ya quinze ou vingt ans en
arrière quand il n'y avait pas tout ça
on a approché un détenu comme tous les
dons maintenant on ira plus dans
l'observation avec des personnes
détenues pour des affaires de moeurs
on les a servera plus que des personnes
détenues pour des petites affaires
car une maison d'arrêt ce sont des
condamnés pour deux ans maximum et
surtout des prévenus post it jaune sur
ce tableau or moi y'en a que j'ai connu
à lyon
après quelques années j'ai été muté je
les ai retrouvés dans une autre prison
et au jour d'aujourd'hui chirurgie
termites et dans une prison je les
retrouve encore peut-il s'en vont on y
croit on se dit que comme ils nous
disent des fois c'est la dernière fois
je reviendrai plus at on les revoit
arrivé bon bah alors on fait ses courses
gagnées y en ait qui vont toujours
arriver avec le sourire qu'ils sont même
contents d'être ici parce que je pense
qu'ils ont chopé des habitudes
à force d'être incarcéré schnurrer fait
désordre
genre d'arrêts voiture mais à
l'extérieur ils sont perdus ils ont plus
de repères elle a pété tout de suite les
reconnaître il a dépassé ligne un
rond-point ouverture de l'alternance
en moyenne les prisons françaises
recense onze agressions de gardiens tous
les jours la violence a changé de nature
elle est sporadique omniprésente avec
les jeunes aujourd'hui le fait de
remettre toujours dans le rapport de
force pratiquement un détenu refusé de
réintégrer ou bloquer des cours pour
pour du tabac pour des petits trucs tout
est prétexte pour pouvoir aller au
conflit bloqués
1800 les conflits étaient moins vous
tient là un conflit c'est que vraiment
il y avait quelque chose d'important
derrière pas totalement je me dis que si
j'avais encore 20 ans aujourd'hui il
faudrait que je tienne des gamins de 20
ans toute la journée avec la violence
aujourd'hui ce serait plus difficile
au jour d'aujourd'hui est ce que je
retiendrai dans ce métier
[Musique]